[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti
continuiamo a kandhar a parlare di
innovazione e cambiamento e nel piccolo
viaggio che ho preparato per noi in
questi quindici minuti piacerebbe
condividere come questi due temi si
sposano col mondo del lavoro e con tante
decisioni che prendiamo in questi ambiti
e spero alla fine di questo piccolo
percorso di sentirmi anche un pochino
meno solo quindi partiamo con la 500 che
mio nonno mi ha lasciato ex bancario in
eredità e sul baule di questa macchina
ho preso un po di informazioni su quello
che siamo su questo mondo per cercare di
renderlo un po più oggettivo quindi ho
chiesto aiuto un mio professore della
bocconi che mi ha dato un po di dati
dell'ocse questa organizzazione che si
occupa per 36 paesi
il merito lo sviluppo economico e
diciamo che quello che emerge che noi
italiani al di là del covip non siamo
mai stati un grosso popolo di
viaggiatori all'estero anti noi odiamo
anche muoversi di provincia in provincia
i bolognesi vogliono stare a bologna i
modenesi a modena a parma non so ci vado
milano roma questo poi è il motivo per
cui anche che tante aziende a volte sono
usciti dall emilia romagna non trovavano
magari manager disposti a trasferirsi a
bologna da milano roma
però io ho continuato a scavare con la
mia valigia sopra 1500 mi son detto
chissà se il sogno di mia nonna
giuseppina che sono un po con un anatema
vittorio trovati un lavoro per la vita
in italia si avvera e devo dire la
verità siamo un paese fortunato perché
in italia secondo l'ocse sempre questo
sogno si avvera siamo il fanalino di
coda in quello che è
la movimentazione durante il corso della
nostra corta vita lavorativa perché
facciano solo 68 69 anni quindi risulta
già un'outsider una persona che ha
cambiato 34 lavoro nella sua vita
io non mi sono perso d'animo ha detto
voglio andare ancora di più a fondo
voglio indagare sempre di più voglio
andare a vedere se il detto cinese
l'apprendimento segue il suo
proprietario per la vita in italia è
vero e me brutta notizia
anche questo detto in italia non è vero
nel senso che l'italia è il fanalino di
coda per il ritorno di investimento su
quello che è università master quindi
non mi sono perso d'animo e ho pensato
va beh sai che c'è magari colpa degli
atenei
vado a vedere in una piccola indagine
che hanno fatto su 2.000 studenti post
universitari qual era lo spirito con cui
avrebbero affrontato il nome del lavoro
e devo dire che gli italiani si sono
subito portati all'attacco pensando che
fondamentalmente le variabili principali
sono due fortuna e qualche amico quindi
mentre gli inglesi tedeschi e gli
americani e ancora credono nel duro
lavoro
noi siamo in ottima compagnia perché
stiamo con ghana bangladesh insomma
diciamo che siamo sul pezzo
allora mi fermo un attimo e dico a
questa è la polaroid che ci rappresenta
cioè questa la polaroid e gli outsiders
e devo dire che con grande tristezza
questo è stato un po il mio mondo
i primi anni dopo l'università e io
volevo un'azienda dinamica ma volevo
tornare a dormire a casa per uscire coi
miei amici
sognava una carriera internazionale ma
volevo viaggiare il giusto insomma devo
dire la verità che mi sono reso conto
che il più grosso nemico di quello che
poteva essere un potenziale out sider è
stato per tantissimo tempo
lui è già vive da questo ora quasi le
undici seduti pensate adesso vittorio
parte con un pippone sulla neuroscienza
e già iniziare il telefonino instagram
linkedin sa che un po di
rimuovere questo tempo a morte in verità
spero di non rimanere da solo quindi
chiedo se avete i telefonini mano
preparateli e preparatevi ad accendere
la luce verso di me che vi voglio
coinvolgere qualche piccola votazione
per capire se solo io ero reduce di
queste trappole mentali oppure qualche
volta che vi date anche voi quindi parto
corà prima che è l'inerzia contro
comportamentale il nostro cervello ad
oggi al nuovo ed è sempre pronto a
prendere qualcosa che conosce questo è
il motivo per cui alcuni di voi hanno
degli amici che fanno tutta la vita un
lavoro che odiano aspettando le vacanze
weekend rimanendo ancorati a quel mondo
e quindi partiamo con la prima votazione
io spero che le signore in sala non si
offendano quanti ometti oggi in piazza
sono affascinati o subiscono il fascino
di questa immagine
avanti con la votazione forza forza
abbiamo poco tempo
bene bene vedo che non sono solo e
questo mi fa piacere diciamo che questo
è un classico esempio di nesta e
comportamentale è stato varato per la
prima volta in un aeroporto ad amsterdam
è diventato un business milionario si
sta sono stati ridotti dell 85 per cento
le spese di pulizia dei bagni l'essere
umano specialmente noi maschietti in
determinati azioni nonostante veda un
obiettivo prettamente finto quindi come
qualcosa di irrazionale lo centra e
continua finché il tutto non è finito
tornando a una seconda trappola visto
che comunque spero di non essere l'unico
che è coinvolto in questi in questi
tranelli
un'altra cosa che chiamata dai tecnici
euristica della rappresentatività
riguarda il quesito che vi sto per fare
qual è la popolazione nera presente oggi
negli stati uniti d'america argomento
super attuale
vedete tutti quello che sta succedendo
nelle piazze in questi giorni gli stati
uniti d'america da sempre integrano
questa visione pensando allo sport
pensate allen trattenimenti primi con
una principessa nera con walt disney
primo supereroe nero oggi tantissimi
nelle piazze combattere propri diritti
se io vi dicessi anche qua un'altra
votazione calcolando che gli stati uniti
d'america abbiamo 320 milioni di persone
e vi chiedo anche qua di votare con me
quindi pronti con i telefoni chi pensa
che il popolo di colore sia più di 150
milioni di persone bene naturalmente chi
non ha votato dice che sono meno e devo
dire che anche qualcosa cervello vi ha
fatto una trappola appreso tutte le
informazioni più veloci che avevate via
ricordate le immagini che subito vi
arrivavano alla mente in verità gli
stati uniti d'america sono un popolo
prettamente bianco 270 milioni di
persone
le persone di colore sono solo il 12 per
cento questa è un'immagine il vostro
vero vi ha dato un ancora via
posizionato leggermente sotto egli ha
fatto dare un dato completamente
scorretto per darvi un altro esempio
visto che prima di me sarà marco io
pochi giorni fa ho comprato un nuovo
smartphone speso imac quasi mille euro
poi il commesso mi ha detto ma perché
non ci mettiamo anche una cover da 59
euro detta come non la mettiamo insomma
mille euro in testa 59 euro non sono
niente poi uscendo ho pensato ma se
arrivasse un ragazzino con un sacchetto
con 20 cover di gomma che fa un totale
di 1000 euro gli do il mio telefono
anche qua diciamo che il mio cervello è
rimasta ancorata mille euro ma detto non
ho detto vai
prendila non costa niente vi lascio con
l'ultimo tranello che
e anche questa abbastanza subdolo che è
chiamato euristica della disponibilità
tornano ancora negli stati uniti
d'america e vi chiedo l'ultima votazione
vi chiedo secondo voi per uscire dalle
polemiche non mi metto qua in italia
trump sarà eletto come nuovo presidente
degli stati uniti d'america e chiedo qua
una votazione ancora veloce con i
telefoni e devo dire che qua
forse siete molto più scaltri di me io
in questo ci sono caduto e poi vi
racconto questa è un giornalista che si
chiama nat silver fa una rubrica molto
molto interessante sul new york times
ogni mese
lui sono vent'anni che vince contro gli
exit poll è partito da lontanissimo
quindi diciamo che lui ha predetto che
ronal reagan avrebbe battuto carter
carta vedete il grafico è stato lui il
presidente americano che ha incrementato
in assoluto i posti di lavoro negli
stati uniti d'america
gli ultimi tre mesi ha avuto una piccola
deva che si è fatto battere da un attore
di hollywood che cinque mesi prima
sparava con le pistole di carta adesso è
qualcosa di più attuale ma nell 80 era
veramente un disastro perché perché il
nostro cervello è ancorato a quelli che
sono gli ultimi avvenimenti specialmente
quelli più negativi
questo è il motivo per cui spesso magari
siete nervosi o siete arrabbiati con il
popolo il vostro lavoro
dopo un bel po che questo evento era
passata e qui torniamo al discorso di
trump aveva un negozio aveva un'auto li
amavo milano distrutte con le proteste
non mi sento più protetto magari avrei
votato biden ma in quella cabina chissà
chi vivrà vedrà
diciamo che potrei tenere banco per
molto ma penso che vogliate andare a
letto
il succo è che oltre a questo c'è anche
un altra pressione
noi siamo animali sociali guardate che
bella questa piazza adoriamo stare in
gruppo e quindi subiamo la pressione del
gruppo specialmente anche quando il
leader o comunque le persone più in
vista ci portano a fare delle decisioni
che poi fondamentalmente potrebbero
andare contro il nostro
interessa e io su questa una candid
camera molto carina fatta su mille
persone tutti attori tranne il
malcapitato nessuno è mai riuscito a
resistere più di tre piani di questo
ascensore dove tutti fanno qualcosa di
assolutamente folle
[Musica]
non tutti
e voglio rimanere con l'immagine di
questa povera ragazza ingobbita in un
ascensore in cui tutti guardano non
verso l'uscita
perché spesso io mi sono ritrovato nelle
sue condizioni dopo l'università aveva
sognato di comunque continuare ingegneri
e ai miei migliori amici stavano
continuando ingegneria la mia famiglia
sognavano lavoro per la vita spesso
durante le riunioni mi sono fatto
influenzare dal mio capo dai colleghi
più anziani più esperti e diciamo che a
posteriori
chi può dire se questo è positivo o meno
vi posso soltanto raccontare che proprio
ingegneria non l'ho mai finita e quindi
forse alcune volte meglio non farsi
influenzare detto questo diciamo che
penso che abbiate capito che la scusa
del lavoro era per farli ragionare sul
cambiamento
immaginate stanno sempre in tema di
viaggi la vostra vita con un aereo
enorme dove caricate lavoro affetti
amicizie famiglie i vostri sogni voi
oggi se del comandante avete il copilota
più pigro e disorganizzato che c'è sulla
pasta della terra che il vostro cervello
il cui unico scopo è quello di non farvi
toccare la tastiera avete mille pulsanti
lui continua a dirgli che qualsiasi
pulsante non succede niente non starà
toccarlo
rimaniamo così come stiamo e in effetti
in un volo aereo su cambi gradi da
bologna a new york in se dovesse andare
a trovare nel sito del giornalista di un
paio di gradi mi perdo tutto quello che
è il nord america
sinceramente il punto con cui vi lascio
sono tre piccoli insegnamenti e chiaro
che in un momento come questo le scelte
tradizionali non pagano
ricordatevi che il vostro cervello è una
macchina molto subdola che combatte il
cambiamento e cercate di impegnarvi ogni
giorno in piccole modifiche senza
puntare subito la luna perché poi lo
porterebbe soltanto a deprimere i
ragazzi vi auguro un volo pieno di
turbolenza quelle persone che amate
vi voglio bene grazie bologna vado a
letto ciao